former CIA director Michael Hayden
believes the intelligence community is
under threat from outside forces
Hayden led the agency under President
George HW Bush and through the start of
the Obama administration retired the
retired Air Force general also ran the
National Security Agency from 1999 to
2005 Hayden's new book is called the
assault on intelligence American
national security in an age of lies it
argues that forces including the Trump
White House make the work of
intelligence officers harder but more
important than ever
general Hayden welcome we get to the
book in a minute but president Trump
said about Isis that that his
administration has done a great job
ridding the region of Isis but there has
now been this attack in Kabul a double
suicide attack where do things actually
stand today so the president has amped
up the pressure on Isis both in
Afghanistan and in Syria a few more
forces maybe a little more local
commander authority to get them some
things done on the battlefield folks
like me celebrate that I call it kind of
Obama plus you know a little more energy
a little more freedom of action but this
is a long-term battle this is not one
way you start spiking the football and
so you see in Syria we're not yet done
and the local commanders are trying to
say it's not time to turn the lights out
and here in Afghanistan actually John
Afghanistan is probably a condition to
be managed not a problem to be solved
we're gonna have to keep the level of
violence there down to an acceptable
level I think for a very long time we
are on the eve of a historic summit
between President Trump and the leader
of North Korea South Korea now just
saying that the North is willing to give
up its nuclear program if there can be
peace on the peninsula in the United
States vows not to attack do you really
believe that North Korea will give up
its program look I I want to be hopeful
that the profession demands me to be
realistic we have been pretty much at
this exact spot three other times under
three other administrations now that's
not my thing we shouldn't give it
another shot
that's not my saying that we've done
some good things the isolation of the
regime the economic pressure all good
the red
last summer may have made us a little
more dangerous than we had to be but
we're moving in a direction that might
give us an opportunity now one thing I I
point out in the book is what's the
intelligence backdrop to the American
negotiating position the intelligence
backdrop to to what it is we've been
doing and if you if you just look at
people currently in office and carefully
read what they say they make the point
that it would almost be irrational for
Kim to give up his weapons and anything
like the current strategic circumstances
so when we say denuclearization
I hope this Intelligence Estimate is
included in what our expectations are
and what our negotiating approach will
be and in addition to that we heard the
president's new national security
adviser yesterday on Face the Nation
talked about verification of that
denuclearization which is a further step
so sorry I think the arc and again I try
to suggest in the book these are wicked
problems and you don't need a president
saying I and I alone and it and they're
and they're still here because the other
guys were stupid and ineffective they're
still here because they're hard and
they're still going to be here after he
leaves in one way or another so again I
hope we have muted expected realistic
expectations here general the book is
called the assault on intelligence what
do you make of the president's
relationship with the intelligence
community at this point so it's had a
bit of a rocky road a good friend of
mine and I use this as an outline in the
book john mclaughlin says the
relationship has gone through four
stages all right first of all was
ignorance I mean he really didn't know
anything about the community that's not
uncommon but I think it was an extra
dose this time simply because he and
members of his team had no no experience
in government it quickly it quickly went
to confrontation because the first time
we had to meet him and discuss was over
an issue that other people were using to
challenge his legitimacy as president
the whole Russian thing we've now gotten
into a zone of what John calls
inevitability you can't live without it
all right and we're existing comfortably
uncomfortably this investigation on
which III know and that's why I said
comfortably uncomfortably some days or a
good day some days or bad days but the
core the core here in even in this
coexistence is the president's view
towards truth and reality and that's the
point I try to make in the book we've
had presidents who disagree with us
we've had presidents who lie we've not
had presidents for whom objective
reality doesn't seem to be compelling
but general people would push back and
say wait a minute in terms the
intelligence agencies you had directed
the CIA saying it was a slam dunk that
weapons of mass destruction there was
wireless warrantless wiretapping going
on for a long time there was not truth
about that I know that and the Senate
Intelligence Committee report on
waterboarding said there were all kinds
of untruths so there was an underlying
ground truth about untruths coming from
the intelligence it was John I get it
hard work but that's an argument about
the truth
all right that's an argument about what
constitutes objective reality I'm saying
over here we have a trend line that
seems to want to make decisions not on
objective reality cases in point the
Muslim man remember about a week out of
the gate the new administration because
why because we had an apocalyptic threat
from Syrian refugees and a absolutely
dystopian vetting system no reality
whatsoever and by the way you don't see
the Intel community even the ones
currently in government arguing for that
it was made based upon something else
not an argument over objective reality
what about the fact that the president
made his the choice to retaliate against
Syria based on an intelligence
assessment of their use of chemical
weapons when he put action behind it he
absolutely did and and and I see
evidence that when it comes to
implementing back to the necessity and
evitable 'ti the president goes to the
intelligence as to how to go do this
what I didn't see it may have happened I
I hope it did but what I what I didn't
see wasn't wasn't a question to the
intelligence community for the broader
context like why did he do that
is he scared or is he overconfident what
were the iranians thinking what were the
russians thinking Michael
and I emphasize this in the book Michael
Gerson has a great phrase for the
president and this is this is the real
challenge for intelligence Michael says
the president lives in the eternal now
there's little history there are a few
consequences the purpose of intelligence
is context it's all about history it's
all about consequences and hence the
challenge we have by the way LG talked
about I talked about the phases we went
from ignorance to OP to opposition to
acceptance inevitability phase four is
when the modal report finally comes out
and you think he'll accept it well
that's why phase four is different from
three we don't know what it is and we
don't know what the response will be but
right now the president has been
chipping away making war dead
legitimizing important institutions like
the Department of Justice and the FBI
can that spread again because he's done
it before
to the intelligence community and the
point I try to make in the book to
people still in government is in
addition to your to your own conscience
you know and being who you are you are
responsible for these institutions for
their survival
you cannot accommodate so much to the
peculiarities and quirks of any one
president that you D legitimize the
institution for history the people and
future presidents well general Hayden
always good to have you
lots hear about a lot of different hot
spots around the world including
Russia's continued disinformation
campaign and how they're trying to
influence our elections thank you so
much for being here we appreciate it
Congrats on the books the assault on
intelligence goes on sale tomorrow